in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Dwight
and Misha are with us hey how are you
are you Dave welcome guys good to have
you where you from right outside of
Columbus Ohio very cool well welcome to
Nashville we're honored to have you with
us and I'm guessing you're here to do a
debt-free scream yes where we are how
much have you paid off nine hundred
eighty thousand holy all right there's a
story here how long did this take a
little over three years sir okay and
what's your range of income during that
three years started 250 and a little
under a million Oh God he says so
nonchalantly okay not familiar I paid
off a million and I make a million oh
well that's me so what the flip do you
do for a living dude I'm an
anesthesiologist pain management
my wife is an ER doctor oh okay two docs
one-two punch boom you are killing it
man that is awesome congratulations I'm
so proud of you Wow I had no idea so
yeah that's a lot of debt I'm guessing
two Doc's worth of debt but a lot of
student loans yes four hundred four
hundred twenty thousand student loan of
the 980
what was the rest of it house personal
home we bought her mother homes let she
take care of our two beautiful children
and we sold a condo okay y'all are so
weird I love it you're awesome this is
amazing
I don't know if we've ever had any buy
on here in front of me that makes a
million dollars or more a year that's
pretty neat so it's very impressive very
impressive I'm giddy all right so but
you know you guys know a lot of docs and
I know a lot of Doc's that make a lot of
money and they're stupid and they just
have they just wallow in bad from what
in the world happened three years ago it
made you guys get on this and pay
everything off well Dave I've been
following your plan for quite some time
and just knew that if we ever want to
retire in dignity we had to pay off the
student loan and just all the changes in
health care you never
if your income is going to stay the same
so you just take care of what you can
when you have it and so we these girls
could have a better life doesn't worry
about that later on
so Myesha mister planner here sits down
and says we make truckloads of money and
we're actually not going to spend it all
we're actually going to use it to pay
off debt what did you say I'm not
working any extra ships yeah our incomes
okay I'm not working extra ships good
because he kind of does he get geared up
about stuff yes very much
he's kind of intense yes yeah just below
the surface cuz he kind of calm on top
right yeah I like it this is great
that's fun
so you guys got on a written budget yes
sir so tell me what happened tell me the
story well I was still in fellowship and
she was working and we just you know we
had all the student loans we want to get
a house and first had our daughter
Kennedy and we decided we could do this
and live pretty low we could still live
on our we made and residency and still
be comfortable so we just you know it's
a big hill when we looked at it was a
number two seemed insurmountable but you
know it's every month we you know just
saved and just kind of Chuck that every
month and we started seeing those debts
get smaller and the biggest thing I
think about to a year and a half ago we
paid off her home that was the next big
step and then about eight months ago we
paid off my issue student loans and so
that really made it so she could
consider staying home with the children
so that was a big part of it
Wow amazing absolutely amazing
very well done because I mean average
you paid off about I mean Counting to
sell the condo but it's not all cash
flow but it's an average of 25,000 a
month so that's pretty ridiculous that's
just nice I love this how do I mean
Myesha when you hear when people hear
that you guys you know you paid off all
of your debt and they asked how did you
do that what do you guys tell them the
secret to getting out of debt is I think
you just have to trust your partner
Dwight's kind of gung-ho sometimes but
you have to trust your partner trust
your instincts and just have faith in
God that it's going to work out mm-hmm
and one of the key components Dwight
from your perspective I think work I was
working for jobs
Myesha we've had
first Easter was our first holiday
together in here she always missed shift
so just knowing there was a bigger cause
and you know when you want to buy the
bigger home buy a nicer car you just you
just keep your nose down and keep
grinding you know don't live like the
Joneses per se mmm Wow how's it feel I'm
just kind of in hey man no dad oh that's
great
he's great going up no dad that's weird
you don't have a house payment you don't
have student loans you could do anything
you want to do I mean the the level of
generosity you guys can pour out will be
mind-boggling very very cool so did you
guys grow up with parents that were wise
with money or not
yeah my parents are very wise with money
my dad is the schoolteacher and they're
getting a PhD so he always set me down
and talked about importance of money and
budgeting so had a budget even going in
college so it was a huge part of that
hmm what about you my sure I grew up in
a single family home and my two had two
older sisters and my mom always said if
we don't have it we don't spend it yeah
there it is just like that so when you
start making money the value system was
already there to keep you from losing
your mind yeah very cool
well congratulations you two you're very
very impressive it's so neat couple of
rock stars in the lobby Ryder man this
is amazing congratulations I'm so proud
of you very very well done thank you all
right Dwight and Meisha now what are
your kiddos names Kennedy and Ava this
is Ava the baby here it was almost a
year in this candy is five years old all
right beautiful family and they are
completely debt-free nine hundred and
eighty thousand dollars paid off in
three years making 250 up to close to a
million count it down let's hear a debt
free scream one two three we're dead
free
I love it Wow
absolutely awesome you guys very very
well done
hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show and so you have to break the
cycle you have to flip this thing on its
head and make it behave you've got to
get so fired up and wired up that you're
broke friends think you've lost your
mind